c'est
parti rien
écran pas prendre un plus large
attendsend
la
et tu asarrê sur celuil c'est pas mal
çaar ok laisse tomber
sens tu ve te mettre t'occupes pas de
moi mettre dans le bon sens pour tu
demand quand tu es lar l'ombre du bateau
va venir en contre
jourir le contrejour sur le bateau tu
vas voir l'ombre du je c'est
intéressant tu vois là pas je sais pas
si tu es moi jeis rien sur mon
écr ok laissz-moi le temps 2
secondes c'est pas non plus je CIS je
sais pas s'il faut la de faire avec
ça
ou dans le
tenir problème tu veux
est faireantutre côté
retrouve c'est
plus
regarde là comme ça tu veux garder là on
est pile ok là tu l' du bateau qui va
arriver que bate un contre jour tu vas
le voir dès qu'il va arriver ça va
être une nombre assez for
ça
arrive
merci B allez c'est une connerie on pe
faire ça je sa pas ce que je vais
pouvoir en faire de ça je sais pas
comment je vais le monter c'est bon pour
toi ou pas ça attends juste 2 secondes
on termine
ouais allez coupe